افادت صحيفه جورنال نقلا عن مسؤولين
امريكيين اداره الرئيس بايدن تدرس اصداره
معلومات استخباراتيه بشان احتمال نقل
الصين اسلحه الى روسيا اضافت الصحيفه ان
الصين كانت حذيره من تشجيع موسكو لانها
قلقه من تداعيات فشل روسيا في الحرب اوضحت
النابجين لن توفر بالضروره اسلحه متطوره
لروسيا لكنها قد تعوض ما خسرته في
اوكرانيا من ذخيره
واشارت جورنال ان المساعدات الصينيه
المحتمله قد تكون عباره عما لا تستطيع
روسيا انتاجه بسبب العقوبات مثل
الالكترونيات واضافه تقييمات
الاستخباراتيه اكدت ايضا قلق بجيل
المتزايد من تهديد بوتين باستخدام القوه
النوويه
نفى المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
وانجوين التي هامات الامريكيه بشان
امكانيه تزويد الصين لروسيا بالاسلحه
ووصفها بالافترات واكد وانجا الصين تعمل
على تعزيز السلام والمحادثات بطريقتها
الخاصه وتلعب دورا مسؤولا وبناء في تخفيف
الوضع وحل ما سماها الازمه الاوكرانيه
ما تسمى بالمعلومات الاستخباريه من الجانب
الامريكي ليست لا تكهنات ومحاولات لتشويه
سمعه الصين فمنذ اندلاع الازمه في
اوكرانيا وقفت الصين بحزم الى جانب الحوار
والسلام ولعبت دورا مسؤولا وبناء في تخفيف
الوضع وحل الازمه من خلال تعزيز محادثات
السلام بطريقتها الخاصه
المقابل قالت كاسلين هيكس نائبه وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه في تغريده على تويتر ان
على بلادها التركيز على الكفاءه القتاليه
لردع ما سمته العدوان الصيني على الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها وشركائها ومصالحها
وهزيمتها اذا تطلب الامر حسب التغريده